within a few years it's hoped this
that's
ibm's q system one quantum computer will
be cracking calculations that would take
a standard
digital computer years today in germany
the first ibm system one in europe will
be presented to the public near
stuttgart
china and the u.s have been working on
quantum computers for years
now europe hopes to catch up ten german
companies have teamed up
in a joint initiative called qtac
including bmw siemens and
bosch to develop applications for the
computer
ibm system one will run those
applications
well for more let's bring in dw's sir
christy plattson who can certainly fill
us in on quantum computing good to have
you with us christy
uh first of all i mean what are actually
the chances
for germany and german companies to
catch up when it comes to the industrial
use of quantum computing
yeah good morning monica so i mean of
course this is the ultimate goal
with this uh with this whole initiative
i mean germany's research minister
has said that uh the country wants to
achieve technological severity so that's
the real idea behind this is is to gain
some of this ground
that germany has lost to the us to china
to these these two countries are much
farther ahead
in this realm and of course are keen on
maintaining uh
their lead i mean you know they have a
lot to gain by keeping other industrial
uh countries dependent on their on their
technology
now that being said uh germany is kind
of a double threat in the sense that
it has both a strong industrial sphere
as well as a lot of really great
research institute
institutes right here at home and uh so
uh what we're what we're hoping to see
or what the country's hoping to see
is uh to kind of combine those uh to to
sort of even the playing field um
and and yeah there's gonna be a real
concerted effort to do that going uh go
ahead now exactly to bring all that
expertise on both sides together because
as you mentioned it when it comes to
research and development germany is
certainly one of the world leaders even
in
quantum technology and as far as i know
the government wants to invest even more
how much money are we talking about
yeah sure so i mean the government said
they want to invest
over a billion uh euros in this project
and that's just
through 2025 um so this is going to be
quite a long-term project so of course
we're going to be talking about
further investments going forward and
you know we have to remember that it's
not just germany involved here the eu's
also stakeholder they have a lot to gain
by having
you know a quantum computing uh whiz
in-house
so to speak and then of course there's
you know we haven't even mentioned the
corporate
players yet you know all these
industrial leaders that that you
mentioned
who've uh publicly committed to to this
technology and
uh you know we can expect them to be
putting their money where their mouth is
as well
what is the long-term goal there
right so let's uh kind of zoom in for a
second on what's happening right now
with this new initiative so what
what uh what this consortium as they're
calling it
wants to do right now is identify
possible use cases for this technology
and then to also identify
uh how algorithms could be developed to
make simple industrial tasks possible so
you know so what do we what can we do
with this and what's realistic
that once they've determined that that
information would then be shared you
know on
a public level and then there would of
cour of course be a regrouping
uh you know deciding how do we go
forward from here in the very long term
we're talking about certain changes to
to technology to industry that are
almost hard for us to understand from
from today's perspective i mean but in a
general level we're talking about
uh you know increa increasing efficiency
of uh of transportation of logistics i
mean we saw
this fiasco when the for the freight uh
ship evermore got stuck in suez canal
a a quantum computer could help sort out
new routes for those
ships that all got lodged there very
quickly we're talking about improving
computer learning making it easier for
computers to understand human speech
to see things um you know so uh
we're we're seeing uh we're talking very
long term here
however so these are just some some
ideas of what we're gonna see
many years down the road right well
given all the challenges we're facing i
think it's time for quantum
quantum computing to really take off
christy platon from dw business thank
you so much
thank you
you